[Music]  anthrax spores do not just die  they settle  they lie in weight  what we're talking about is a ticking  time bomb  i saw it with my own eyes  [Music]  get out  america has many enemies  i'm here to warn you  an attack is inevitable  i need a team at capitol hill right now  fbi stand and calmly exit the building  i got a hole blown by a weapons attack  on our hands  i need you to catch who did this  even in a vacuum how do you trust  someone with the safety of our nation  i think you're letting all this get to  you i just think something's a mess  i have to find who did this  there are ways to protect ourselves  i encourage everyone not to overreact  here  how bad is this  it's 100 lethal  we can't afford to waste time  what if the anthrax killer's one of us  [Music]  you